hey guys Pete peppers here and we are
looking at candy crush soda saga in the
fishing tournament so when you this
comes out once a week most players have
it now if they if you don't have it on
mobile you'll probably be getting it in
the next really soon
it seems to roll out slow so everybody
more and more people have been getting
it so we click on Tippi in her little
fishing hat and we get get a gift and
unlock a limited time event when you
catch 20 fish does it and we only get to
keep them if we pass the level right so
with you can play any level out of all
825 so I choose to go back to the very
beginning and there's two levels that I
think are kind of excuse me I think
you're kind of the best in there they're
good for different reasons level six is
a very simple level that you will be
just about every time even when you
don't try to even when you don't try to
you know save the bear you end up saving
bear so I'm gonna catch fish you see we
get a big pop up there that indicates
that we collected with one fish and
those we don't have a meter or anything
we don't see that till later but those
just wait to see I guess you could say
if we finish the level so what I'm doing
right now is I'm just looking for places
where I can sit down like some fish and
it's not actually coming very well let
it down let's see what happens as a fish
there's another fish so yeah you just
wanna when you're playing this
particular level number six then you can
keep it on your moves obviously but you
just want to look for places to make
fish and setting the fish off doesn't
have anything to do as you can see you
get the plus one when you actually make
the match so here we have a choice if
you can make a rat or straight I strike
to our fish zombies fish and you get
seven moves left don't want to lose the
ones you have so now I'll kind of look
at finish from the level so the way this
works beyond the beyond the collections
is all of your friends are collecting -
and first things first once we collect
20 of them we're gonna get the
tournament to start right now we're just
going we're just going for a up a double
delish fish which is the you know the
fish booster that you can um you can set
up into four level starts
so I'll click out of there and you see
we collected seven fish and what I'm
gonna do now is I'm going to collect
instead of making you watch me play
these levels again I'm going to pause it
collect the rest and then we'll talk
about the tournament how it works all
right so I played level six a few more
times and I got my 20 fish that you see
I get one free double delish fish and
I'll collect that and now it's time to
tell us about the tournament and so if
you've unlocked a special event compete
with other players and continue
collecting fish to relent even sweeter
rewards so here's the leaderboard I have
23 the person inverse has 350 so I'm
pretty far behind what what you need to
do I think this will just give us that
same pop up yeah so what you need to do
is just play over and over again and
collect fish I've found that level eight
is a good level there's mixtli to six is
like if you want to just slow and steady
collect fish without losing so you get
them every time eight is a little bit of
a harder level even though it's an early
level you can see here I'm Pearson love
double delish fish and set that up in
the beginning if you want to use it just
like your color bombs in your enemies
eight is one where you're gonna collect
a lot more fish but at the same time
it's a tougher level and help say
they've changed it a little bit they put
some stuff on the outside so that might
make it a little bit easier but what I
like about level eight is that you get a
lot of fish and Cascades too so
you collect them at a faster rate and
you can kind of do like a little
experiment and see how many you collect
in a certain amount of time like you
play level six for I don't know 20
minutes count how many fish you collect
and then try playing level eight you
know some people will be better at
certain levels the thing about the thing
keep in mind if you're going to play
level eat though is don't just make fish
because you won't finish you're gonna
need to make big combos in order to beat
the levels successfully and you know
there's no there's no advantage to
catching a lot of fish if you don't
actually finish the level so what some
of the you know strategy tips we
actually have a level eight guide you
can check out I'll put a link in the in
the thing but you know you these outside
areas are obviously the hard parts and
so you're gonna want to make you know a
lot of big combos to spread out and hit
those sections like I'm not up to a very
good start right now so we'll see if I
can turned around a little bit
definitely needed to get some combos you
can see that you can see how I'm
collecting fish just as the pieces come
in without even really trying to do
another one good combos for level eight
are strike plus rad obviously all bomb
combos are gonna be very helpful and I'm
pretty sure like that they just updated
this I mean they might have did it last
week I didn't really play the fishing
tournament the last time but it seems
easier now so I would say that level
eight is probably the best level
you also need to finish it
so another thing a couple other tips for
the fishing tournament in general --he
the ones you make with the balls like
you know if you make color bomb plus a
fish that doesn't really count or at
least it didn't when it first came out
it's more of it's just really the ones
you match for the ones that match in
and combos or cascade sorry
and
you know so some people are gonna play
like a lot what you win when you win is
you win those dudes like you know the
top places get this urgent you coming
first you get I got a ton of them and
then it just goes down every time after
that so these if we catch them here in
the in the in this big cascade that
happens at the end we also get to count
them so having extra moves left at the
end is a pretty good deal but other than
that I mean it's just a you know the the
promotion has I would say that they want
people to continue to play even when
there aren't new levels or when they're
stuck it gives them something else to do
so it's pretty cool you know you can get
you can definitely get some boosters
from it you can see I didn't go up that
much that time but it's not like the
bubblegum pill where you're guaranteed
to get something and so you know there's
there's pros and cons to it
one trick is if you figure out when well
one trick that's worked is if you figure
out when it's gonna end if you start
with just a few hours left what it did
in the past was it it had set it up so
that you would play other players at
that time like for example if I quit now
which I'm gonna do after I make this
video all the other people on my list
will likely keep playing so I won't even
come close in the end to - winning
winning the tournament so in that way
it's kind of like well do I really want
to play the game for the next 17 hours
what you could do instead is you could
wait till there's like an hour left or
two hours left in the promotion you'd
have to coordinate with someone to find
out one that's happening like in our
group I know people were doing that last
week to figure out where the time frame
was so that they didn't have to spend
three days playing the tournament
and then you have a much more realistic
shot because you're only up against
people who are who are playing for the
same amount of time as you are so if you
pick a good level like this one and play
it over and over you have a pretty good
chance of finishing in the top it's sort
of like bubble gum pill in a way I mean
a lot of people use the cheat cheat
stuff in the game you know they get a
modified version of the program or
whatever so that they get extra moves
and things like that so they can really
run it up and it kind of skews the
results but overall I mean I noticed
last week that a lot of people were
posting that they had one or they you
know they got a good prize for being the
top of the thing so I think if you just
sort of figure you know playing it out a
little bit like play the best level for
you then you know you'll feel partnered
to be pretty cool I I kind of jumped
around levels the first time I came out
to see what I could find the night I I
recommend staying at the early part like
I said of you if you find that you can't
get through level 8 very consistently
and you're not keeping them then level 6
will work I found it I found that I got
pretty bored one another just playing
level 6 just because it's not much going
on in it but like I said you you you
will like basically finish it every
single time so you know it's not like
you
it's not like you won't get yourself
some rewards that way so you can let me
know in the comments what levels you
like to play talk to some other people
down there and see what you think
do you like the fishing tournament what
would you like to see change about it
let us know and I'll be making new
videos soon so make sure you subscribe
to the channel and give us a like for
the video Thanks